hey folks Chris waters here standing in
for reviewer Justin Clark some of your
greatest moments in Kerbal space program
are likely to be failures you endured
disaster after disaster keeping the
little green men that inhabit this
universe alive in the cold blackness of
space and then their ship crashes into
the moon which means the end for them
but it also means triumph for you
their commander you finally made it
after all that time spent trying and
tweaking and now it's time to try again
and hopefully to stick the landing this
time trying to nutshell Kerbal space
program isn't so much a matter of
straightforward you win if you get here
goals the game never stops because
there's an entire solar system waiting
out there to be explored what the game
values above all else is perseverance
you advance by simply having the
boldness to reach a little higher if you
manage to break the world speed record
then you're ready to try reaching the
upper atmosphere if you can get there
then maybe we can put an astronaut in
space and if we can reach space maybe we
can reach our closest planetary neighbor
most of your time and game is spent in
the Vehicle Assembly Building on
constant trial-and-error mode trying to
build a craft that can do exactly what's
required for the mission at hand there
are literally hundreds of design options
and moving parts to assemble from fuel
tanks and rockets to the heat shields
for re-entry and the decoupling devices
for boosters and you'd better take it
all into consideration or your vessel
will crash and burn before you even see
the Stars the actual crafting process is
dirt simple where every part is attached
to your craft like Legos there's a slew
of fine tuning tools available for the
more meticulous player but it's a long
time before they become necessary evils
during the design process you have to
plan for every stage of the mission you
need to stockpile enough fuel to make it
there and back and you've always got to
keep in mind your ships stability
and once you've got your spacecraft the
real struggle begins and your real
opponent is gravity gravity is what
keeps craft from lifting off because
you've got too much fuel or not enough
boosters and it's what you will fight
all the way into the upper atmosphere
trying to put spacecrafts in orbit
instead of watching them fall helplessly
back to the ground there are three
different modes in Kerbal space program
sandbox mode opens up every available
part in the game for you to just fool
around with the most elaborate and
insane designs imaginable in science
mode you earn points for every new
milestone you achieve and then spend
them on the research and development
skill tree which is where you earn
bigger and better parts to use career
mode is a full-blown space program
experience where money is an object and
public donations and government
contracts are required to even afford to
send astronauts on a flight this mode is
the most gamey of them all with
contracts representing clearly defined
missions you can perform to get the most
out of every flight Kerbal space program
was in beta for years before this its
official release funny enough even after
all that time there are still some
scattered bugs throughout like ships
occasionally disappearing and orbital
paths turning twitchy and changing at
random even while your ship follows the
one you set but these are nitpicks
compared to what feels like the
cumulative achievements of thousands of
minds bringing their expertise to the
table you see it in the hundreds of
tweaks done over the years and in the
lovingly crafted mods which are easily
accessible and promoted in game even
nasa's gotten in on it with a few of
their own hypothetical scenarios
pre-loaded in the game right from the
get-go you will fail at Kerbal space
program but you will eventually find
success it will demoralize you it will
stress you out but more often than not
it will also soothe you and inspire you
every failure has a lesson to impart and
every lesson brings you closer to a new
accomplishment successes in Kerbal space
program may be hard earned but they're
all the sweeter for it whether you're
escaping the atmosphere for the very
first time or planting a flag on an
unexplored planet
you